♪ ♪
>> Laura: JOINING US TO DECODE
THE MEDIA FREAK OUT AMONG THE
RELEASED MUELLER REPORT AS WELL
AS THE AVENATTI NEWS, SORT OF A
MONDAY WITH TWISTS.
THE OFFER OF THE NEW BOOK,
RAYMOND, YOU WORKED CLOSELY
WATCHING MEDIA REACTION WHEN THE
LETTER DROPPED ON FRIDAY.
>> Raymond: LAURA THIS IS THE
MUELLER MELTDOWN.
AS TIME WENT ON THE MEDIA ICONS
REGAINED THEIR FOOTING AND
STARTING -- STARTED WITH NEW
NARRATIVES BUT THE REALITY OF
IT, THE ACTIONS WERE TELLING.
>> NO FURTHER INDICTMENTS.
NO CHARGES AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
WHY WAS THERE NEVER
INTERROGATION OF THIS PRESIDENT?
HOW CAN THEY LIT TRUMP OFF OF
THE HOOK?
>> Laura: YOU KNOW, LOWER AT
THEO EMOTIONAL ATTACHMENT WAS SO
SEVERE IN THE CASE OF
CHRIS MATTHEWS AS HE FELT A
NARRATIVE FLIPPING AWAY.
YOU SEE HIM OVERCOME WITH ANGER.
AND IF BRIAN CRANSTON WANTS TO
LEAVE BROADWAY, THEY MIGHT FILL
IN HIM FOR THE EVENING REFORM.
RACHEL KNIGHT HAD A ROUGH --
RACHEL MOUNTAIN, SHOCKING COMMIT
DEVASTATING MSNBC NARRATIVE SO S
DEVASTATING MSNBC NARRATIVE SO E
DEVASTATING MSNBC NARRATIVE SO D
DEVASTATING MSNBC NARRATIVE SO C
DEVASTATING MSNBC NARRATIVE SO O
DEVASTATING MSNBC NARRATIVE SO T
DEVASTATING MSNBC NARRATIVE SO N
THE LETTER BUT ON THE PROCESS OF
DELIVERING THE LETTER, WATCH.
IT JUSTICE DEPARTMENT STAFFER OR
MESSENGER OF SOME ALL WE KNOW A
NORTH FACE JACKET BROUGHT IN
FACT, TWO LETTERS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TWO MANILA
ENVELOPES AND AT HIS NEW YORK
OFFICE, NOT INDICES OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF MADE A DIGITAL
COPY AND GOT THE LETTER TO HIM
THAT WAY.
>> Laura: WEIGHT COMMIT WAS A
NORTH FACE JACKET A NORTH FACE
JACKET?
>> Raymond: IT IS UNBELIEVABLE
BUT NEVER GOT TO THE NARRATIVE
UNTIL AFTER THE SHOW THE LADIES
AT THE VIEW A FEW MONTHS AGO
SINGING IMPEACHMENT SONG LISTEN.
>> HE GOES TO JAIL, HE GOES TO
JAIL, HE GOES TO JAIL.
>> Laura: BUT TODAY THEY WERE
LESS YOU WILL ABOUT THE
EXONERATION OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> NO EVIDENCE THAT THE GUY IN
THE WHITE HOUSE CONSPIRED WITH
RUSSIA.
>> WHAT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED